bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne
l'audition de dominique baudis le
défenseur des droits par la commission
des lois du sénat
à son arrivée à la tête de cette
nouvelle institution dominique baudis
était succès plusieurs objectifs dont
celui de faciliter l'accès au défenseur
des droits
en implantant sur tout le territoire
français des délégués de cette
institution alors at il rempli ses
objectifs et bien éléments de réponse
avec cette audition les défenseurs chers
amis chers collègues d'abord je dors
excusé jean pierre sueur qui retenu dans
une autre commission
je peux comment elle s'appelle de la
sécurité la délégation pour le
renseignement donc il nous rejoindra en
cours de matinée et donc il m'a demandé
de présider et s'est excusé je crois que
dominique par téléphone c'est pour
éviter de cette réunion donc vous le
savez nous recevons ce matin le
défenseur des droits qui depuis sa
nomination en juin 2011 est devenu
défenseur des droits monsieur défenseur
vous savez notre commission est
traditionnellement attachés à la
préservation des droits et des libertés
veiller à son application afin
d'effectivité nous avons reçu avant la
la suspension de la cession je crois 6
mars
monsieur delarue qui nous a fait un
bilan de son activité sur la gestion et
que qui nous a commenté le rapport qu'il
avait déposé la veille ou l'avant-veille
je crois le président de la république
et aujourd'hui vous succédera monsieur
jean paul costa qui parlera un peu sur
le plan européen du respect de ses
droits et de libertés mais aussi comme
je vous le disais à l'instant et
peut-être ont pu y revenir
nous avons avec patrice gélard et moi
même une petite mission que la
commission des lois nous a données pour
voir un peu dans quelle voie allait se
diriger la cour européenne compte tenu
je dirais d'un assaut même s'il n'est
pas très enfin quand même de la grande
bretagne
prenant prétexte certains
dysfonctionnements de la cour c'est vrai
d'un retard considérable pour peut-être
mettre en cause un certain nombre voilà
donc là dessus vous nous direz également
et vous serez défendu informer si vous
souhaitez du rapport et les auditions et
des travaux que l'on pourra faire de
nous voulons évidemment recueillir votre
votre impression premières impressions
sur le premier bilan que vous pouvez
faire de l'auto de la nouvelle autorité
constitutionnelle que vous présidez
vous avez pris la succession de trois
autorités administratives indépendantes
de quatre autorités me steeve
indépendante
cette manière de faire a donné lieu ici
à quelques réserves et quelques
discussions non la loi est là elle doit
être appliquée et pour le faire vous
êtes assisté de deux adjoints que vous
avez trouvé recruter si j'ose m'exprimer
ainsi
deux collèges et il sera intéressant de
savoir pour la commission comment après
quelques mois d'exercice vous
fonctionnez ce plan je dirais procédure
orale on peut dire que entre les
adjoints les commissions et les
différents sujets maintenant que que
vous avez à traiter qui sont dans votre
compétentes de daube ousmane on peut
dire à la française et puis également
une interrogation s'étaient élevées ici
au parc et au parlement est ici
particulièrement sur les moyens dont
vous disposerez les moyens humains les
moyens matériels pour mener à bien cette
mission constitutionnelle donc là aussi
vous apporterez certainement la
commission un stand de précision et
peut-être vous répondrai aux questions
de du rapporteur de ce budget qui est à
naples est ce que je remercie pour sa
présence comme je vous remercie
également tous qu'ils avaient bien voulu
assister à cette audition dans une
période où nous sommes pas tous présents
mais où je vois quand même que la
qualité la qualité et la cise aux pieds
voilà donc je vous donne la parole pour
le temps que vous convient entre 20 et
30 minutes 20 minutes c'est bien puis
après on pourra passer à des les
questions de nos collègues merci merci
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
mesdames messieurs de de votre
invitation et de votre présence je vais
dans le temps qui m'est imparti monsieur
le président essayez de vous dresser un
tableau aussi complet que possible de la
mise en oeuvre de la construction de
cette institution nouvelle du défenseur
des droits et de la mise en oeuvre
des pouvoirs qui lui ont été confiées
par la loi organique du mois de mars
alors l'institution tout d'abord et ce à
sa construction
mon premier souci en prenant mes
fonctions a été de sauvegarder à
l'intérieur de l'institution unique
la spécificité des quatre missions qui
sont explicitement confié au défenseur
des droits médiation avec le service
public défense des enfants déontologie
de la sécurité lutte contre les
discriminations et promotion de
l'égalité
cette sauvegarde de la spécificité des
missions s'opère d'une part par la
présence vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président d'adjoint en l'occurrence
d'adjointe puisque pour ces trois
fonctions j'ai choisi trois femmes parce
que j'ai trouvé dans les auditions j'ai
pu conduire trois personnes qui étaient
des personnes de terrain avec une bonne
expérience des sujets enfants
discrimination déontologie donc voilà il
ya ce dispositif d'adjointe crée
d'ailleurs par la loi organique et dont
les compétences ont défini par la loi
organique
par ailleurs la spécificité des missions
se traduit également par la présence des
collèges également créé par la loi
organique de collèges de 8 ans collège
de 6 à aussi sur les sujets
discrimination déontologie de la
sécurité défense des enfants et puis la
sauvegarde de ce qui a été fait depuis
six ans à la halle depuis plus de dix
ans la défense des enfants se manifeste
également par la présence des agents qui
travaillaient dans les quatre
institutions les trois que j'ai cité
plus le médiateur de la république et
les personnes qui travaillaient là sont
toujours là à quelques exceptions près
parce qu'il ya eu quelques départs à la
retraite on pourra vous donner les
précisions sur cette évolution des
effectifs mais il n'y a pas eu de perte
en ligne
a pas eu de perte de mémoire de perte
d'expérience le défenseur des droits
regroupe les agents des quatre autorités
administratives indépendantes
de même d'ailleurs que les quatre
budgets vous avez évoqué monsieur le
président la question des moyens
elle été tranchée par le législateur le
défenseur des droits reprend les
dossiers qui étaient en cours d'examen
dans les quatre structures il reprend
les agents des quatre structures
il reprend les budgets des quatre
structures à quelques ajustements près
liées à la conjoncture avec voilà les
parts de crédit qui sont gelés mais en
faisant cela on est traité comme
l'ensemble des administrations ou des
autorités administratives indépendantes
donc sauvegarde
c'était mon premier souci deuxième
objectif gagner en efficacité grâce au
rapprochement des quatre autorités
effectivement c'est bien sauvegarder
mais si on ne sait que sauvegarder après
tout on pouvait rester dans l'état
antérieur
il fallait valoriser le potentiel de
synergies dégagées par le rapprochement
je vais vous donner des exemples
concrets qui vont vous permettre de
mesurer à quel point on gagne en
efficacité
le médiateur de la république par
exemple avait un pôle santé et sécurité
des soins pour tous qui était médiation
entre un patient et un praticien patient
est un établissement hospitalier avec un
collège de médecins bénévoles qui se
réunit régulièrement et beaucoup de
dossiers qui sont traités donc un pôle d
expertise médicale exister chez le
médiateur de la république mais
évidemment ni la défense des enfants ni
la déontologie de la sécurité ni la
lutte contre les discriminations n'avait
accès au pôle santé et sécurité des
soins
or dans ces trois domaines sur les
enfants sur une contre expertise
médicale sur une affaire de déontologie
de la sécurité quelqu'un ayant trouvé la
mort ou italie a été blessé dans une
opération d'interpellation qui tourne
mal
les questions de discrimination pour
l'âge pour l'état de santé pour le
handicap sur toutes ces questions
évidemment les avis du pôle santé et
sécurité des soins sont précieux dans
l'est
fonction des dossiers aujourd'hui toutes
les missions peuvent recourir à ce à ce
pôle
un autre exemple de d'efficacité gagné
dans leur rapprochement le défenseur des
enfants quand ils recevaient un dossier
qui relevait plutôt de la médiation avec
les services publics
transmettez ce dossier au médiateur de
la république s'était d'ailleurs prévue
par la loi créant l'institution du
défenseur des enfants qui dit
transmission du premier examen du
dossier décision le transmettent
transmission examen du dossier par
l'autre institution
c'est un mois et demi de perdus voilà
donc aujourd'hui il ya une seule porte
d'entrée
il n'y a pas de réorientation des
dossiers d'une structure à l'autre comme
c'était le cas auparavant
dernier exemple le réseau territorial
j'ai trouvé trois réseaux celui des
délégués du médiateur de la république
que la plupart d'entre vous connaissent
parce qu'ils sont très présents dans les
départements environ 300 personnes
un réseau de correspondants de la halde
environ une centaine de personnes et un
réseau correspondant de la défense des
enfants environ trentaine de personnes
ça signifie que dans plus de la moitié
des départements les deux tiers des
départements
il n'y avait pas une personne pour
représenter les intérêts supérieurs de
l'enfant la défense des enfants et si on
voulait atteindre un représentant de
cette institution
parfois il fallait les dans la région
voisine aujourd'hui j'ai regroupé les
trois réseaux ce qui fait un seul et
unique réseau de 430 personnes qui
reçoivent le public sur 650 points
d'accueil métropole et outre-mer et au
cours ne s'était bien 2012 on procède
région par région à un cycle de
formation pour l'ensemble de ses
délégués de façon à ce qu'il soit
capable de juger
de la recevabilité d'un dossier que
quelqu'un vient leur présenter et ce
réseau c'est une force extraordinaire
je rappelle que ce sont des personnes
bénévoles qui sont défrayés à 350 euros
par mois sur des personnes bénévoles et
se sont pas simplement des personnes de
bonne volonté sont des personnes
compétentes pour la plupart de nouveaux
retraités pour la plupart également
issus de la fonction publique ayant
tuant un général du niveau de
responsabilité élevée une très belle
expérience professionnelle et qui le
jour de la retraite arrivée et décide de
consacrer bénévolement une part de leur
temps à l'intérêt général
donc c'est extrêmement précieux parce
que ça permet d'établir un lien physique
personnel entre les citoyens les
réclamants et notre institution
on ne travaille pas que sur la base des
échanges de mails et de courriers
il y a pour au moins la moitié des cas
ces rencontres avec les délégués
territoriaux
là aussi donc on gagne dans la
couverture grâce au rapprochement des
trois raisons au cours de ces dix mois
d'exercice de la fonction j'ai veillé à
mettre en oeuvre les moyens juridiques
nouveaux que le législateur nous a
donnés de façon à mieux faire respecter
les droits
je vais vous donnez là aussi quelques
exemples nous sommes confrontés depuis
plusieurs années à la question des
procès verbaux a justifié c'est à dire
des personnes qui longtemps après avoir
vendu leurs véhicules continuent de se
voir réclamer le paiement d'amendés au
titre de ce véhicule qui n'est plus le
leur ces deux lors d'une dizaine de
dossiers par jour qui nous arrive est
sûre sur ce sujet on s'est trouvé un
jour avec quelqu'un
qui avait engagé une grève de la faim il
en était à 150e procès verbal alors
évidemment reconnais c'est bien cette
personne puisque pour lui comme pour
tant d'autres on intervenait en
permanence pour faire annuler les procès
verbaux mais j'aurais bien si raconté il
était interviewé la glace de la fabre et
il hier matin j'ai une lettre du
défenseur des droits en me disant le pv
numérotant est annulé mais dans le même
courrier
j'avais une lettre me réclamant à
nouveau un autre procès verbal is ça
finira jamais avec les moyens qui
étaient ceux du médiateur auparavant on
ne pouvait pas aller plus loin il aurait
fallu continuer pv par pv à faire
annuler là j'ai utilisé le pouvoir
d'injonction qui nous a été donnée par
la loi organique et j'ai fait injonction
à la ministre du budget et au garde des
sceaux de mettre fin désormais à toutes
poursuites à l'encontre de ce monsieur
au titre de ce véhicule qui n'est plus
le sien depuis quatre ans et dans l'est
avec un délai de 48 heures et dans les
48 heures j'ai reçu de madame pécresse
de monsieur mercier une lettre disant
très bien donc nous donnant les
instructions nécessaires
nous avons également utilisé à un
pouvoir important qui nous a été donnée
par le législateur c'est à dire la
capacité de procéder à des vérifications
sur place dans des locaux publics ou
privés et on l'a fait notamment à la
suite d'un arrêt de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et en cela on
rejoint les problématiques que vous
évoquerez tout à l'heure avec monsieur
costa suite à l'arrêt popov rendu au
mois de janvier
popov contre france
popov et tente une famille
d'azerbaidjan je crois enfin d'asie
centrale qui avait été en centre de
rétention administrative pendant
quelques jours avec leurs enfants
mineurs dont certains en bas âge ces
personnes avaient saisi la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
condamné la france
le médiateur de la république avait la
responsabilité d'un suivi de des arrêts
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme donc à ce titre le défenseur des
droits doit l'exercer et à partir de cet
arrêt j'ai demandé à ce que à chaque
fois que la présence de mineurs dans un
centre de rétention administrative de
lui signaler en général par les
associations nous nous rendions sur
place pour le vérifier et donc en
l'espace de trois semaines ou un mois on
a procédé à plus d'une dizaine de
vérification à lyon à metz à roy au
mesnil amelot
lorsque nous étions alerter sur la
situation dans chaque cas on a compté on
l'a constaté effectivement la présence
de mineurs parfois de deux des nouveaux
nés âgés de quelques semaines
à chaque fois j'ai alerté
le ministère de l'intérieur et à chaque
fois une solution d'hébergement
d'urgence a été trouvé dans la tente du
moment où ces personnes seraient
raccompagnés à la frontière
ce pouvoir de vérification sur place les
défenseurs des enfants ne l'avait pas et
d'ailleurs je rencontre souvent madame
versini bas lambrissés qui me lisent ray
nous plusieurs fois on nous signalait la
présence d'un bébé dans un commissariat
où vous voulez y aller on n'avait pas le
droit d'entrer
aujourd'hui on peut vérifier ce qui
évidemment donne davantage de poids à
notre intervention puisque on
n'intervient pas sur des sur des
hypothèses concernant la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme parce que cela
fait partie également nos prérogatives
nous serons amenés parfois à déposer des
observations à l'occasion d'un recours
qu'il peut introduire être introduits
auprès la cod h
je suis allé à strasbourg et une dizaine
de jours pour rencontrer le nouveau
président qui est un britannique comme
vous savez j'ai vu le juge français
poteau ce qui est notre collège enfin
l'ensemble des trois collèges que j'ai
réunis récemment à entendu monsieur
costa sur ces problématiques de
relations complexes entre notre droit
interne et les arrêts de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme avec
parfois des contradictions entre les
arrêts de la cour de cassation et ceux
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
le sénateur gérard qui approuve c'était
une matière juridique complexe
je serai donc très très intéressé
d'ailleurs par tous que par les changes
que vous aurez tout à l'heure
dernier point j'ai veillé à ce que nous
agissions bien sûr toute la gamme des
moyens qui nous sont données nous avons
quatre missions mais nous avons trois
modes d'intervention le premier c'est le
principal
et évidemment c'est le traitement des
réclamations on est sur environ cent
mille personnes chaque année
qu'ils s'adressent à nous alors sur
différents sujets médiation enfin en
discrimination
souvent d'ailleurs des questions
transversales je cite souvent comme
exemple de de l'utilité du rapprochement
une famille dans le jeune fille et c'est
pas une histoire imaginaire je les
trouvais et on la voit souvent et il
vous en connaissez tous dans vos
départements
une famille dont le fils souffre de
handicaps se déplace en fauteuil
sept familles rencontrent des
difficultés pour l'inscrire dans un
établissement d'enseignement
il ya trois manières de résoudre le
problème
cette famille pouvait aller chez le
médiateur demandant qu'on appela nice sa
difficulté elle pouvait demander à la
défense sur les enfants d'intervenir
puisque c'est un mineur elle pouvait
demander à la halle de se saisir du
dossier puisqu'il souffre d'un handicap
et et donc d'une discrimination
voilà au lieu de se demander par quelle
porte entre et éventuellement ailleurs
par les trois que vous êtes beaucoup de
gens là il ya une porte d'entrée unique
et puis qu'on essaie de résoudre le
problème au mieux donc les dossiers
c'est l'essentiel de notre activité mais
nous avons encore deux modes
d'intervention d'une part la promotion
des droits et de l'égalité
c'est à faire du préventif observer les
situations rechercher les meilleures
solutions diffuser les bonnes pratiques
parmi les acteurs de l'accès à l'emploi
du déroulement de carrière de l'accès au
logement
un exemple nous allons et je crois que
ce sera documents importants
nous allons publier la semaine prochaine
un guide pratique de mesure de la
diversité dans l'entreprise
guide pratique que nous avons élaborée
avec la cnil pour essayer de sortir du
problème dans lequel se trouvent les
chefs d'entreprise ou les drh des
grandes entreprises
on nous demande d'introduire de la
diversité dans l'entreprise mais on nous
interdit de la mesurer et donc on fait
rien puisqu'on veut pas compter d'autres
disent pas si on veut faire à tout prix
il se lance parfois dans les procédures
qui peuvent être hasardeuse sur le plan
juridique
avec ce guide pratique établie avec la
cnil les responsables du recrutement et
du déroulement de carrière pour en
mesurer la diversité dans leurs
entreprises mais dans le cadre de règles
qui ne pourront voilà qu'ils pourront
jamais se voir reprocher quoi que ce
soit ce sont des procédures validées par
la cnil
enfin propositions de réforme
c'est un département qui est dirigé par
martin petit site quitte ici elle et
elle a été entendue récemment par le
président de la commission je veux pas
les énoncés puisqu'on a plusieurs
réformes qui sont qui ont été plus en
projet de réforme qui ont été adressées
aux présidents des deux assemblées
certains ont été votés il ya un texte
par exemple que nous avions proposée qui
a fait l'objet d'une proposition de loi
à l'assemblée sur la question du délai
de prescription pour les incitations à
la haine ou à la discrimination et les
délais de prescription n'était pas les
mêmes selon qu'il s'agisse par exemple
d'appel à la discrimination pour des
raisons d'origine ou pour d
raison d'homophobie donc on and on
allait souhaiter ça a été voté par
l'assemblée
l'alignement des délais de prescription
et je crois que cette proposition est à
l'heure actuelle transmise au sénat j'ai
pas si votre commission on a eu
connaissance voilà on a cette activité
de propositions de réforme
je fais une proposition également le
jour en à journée mondiale contre le
sida ancs le moment à ce qu'il soit mis
fin à un dispositif discriminatoire qui
écarte systématiquement les homosexuels
hommes du don du sang alors c'est une
disposition qui avait été prise au début
des années 80 début de la pandémie on
pouvait comprendre que dans l'ignorance
le brouillard dans lequel on était à
l'époque on ait pris des mesures de
cette nature mais aujourd'hui avec le
recul on sait bien que le risque n'est
pas liée à l'orientation sexuelle mais
simplement au fait de savoir si les
jantes une conduite responsable protéger
ou pas donc voilà ce sont des les
propositions que nous ne pouvons fermer
ensuite évident après c'est soit le
pouvoir exécutif soit le parlement qui
en disposent voilà j'étais un peu trop
long sur le président désolé mais je
voulais aussi que merci merci beaucoup
c'est beaucoup dans un temps
relativement bref dont je pense qu'on va
de modiano collègues qui peut poser
quelles sont peut-être madame plesse
voudra commencer vous
je serais d'accord parce qu'elle doit
nous quitter vers 10h30 donc on peut
donner la parole d'abord où pourrait lui
répondre et puis après on fera un petit
tour
on ressent bras les questions d'accord
vas-y mérignies merci monsieur le
président je vais essayer de ne pas être
trop longue effectivement pour laisser
aussi tous mes collègues poser des
questions d'autant que vos services et
les services de la commission des lois
sont en train de travailler pour trouver
d'autres moments de rendez vous pour
parler effectivement de programmation
budgétaire
j'avais posé déjà effectivement un
certain nombre de questions toutes n'ont
pas de réponse mais toutes n'auront pas
non plus aujourd'hui c'est normal
puisque j'ai appris ce matin notamment
que vous travaillez sur les indicateurs
d'évaluation donc je ne voudrais pas la
question aujourd'hui j'attendrai
j'attends un petit peu peut-être quand
même pouvez vous nous dire un petit peu
ou où vous pensez en être en matière
d'image et de connaissance du grand
public de cette nouvelle institution
depuis les quelques mois qui sont passés
aussi depuis là sa création en matière
de locaux je suppose que les choses
n'ont pas beaucoup bougé mais j'aurai je
pense l'occasion de me rendre sur place
pour pouvoir vraiment de fin de visu
comment ça se passe en matière de
personnel aussi et d'intégration des
différents statuts de l'ensemble du
personnel je sais pas si les choses ont
déjà beaucoup évolué ou si vous avez
encore besoin de quelques mois pour pour
nous répondre
j'avais peut-être des questions
peut-être un peu plus ciblées pour
aujourd'hui
avez vous été saisis ou vous êtes vous
intéressé de cette question qui semble
faire un peu débat aujourd'hui autour
des tests biologiques osseux pour
déterminer l'âge des enfants des
conditions dans lesquelles ces tests
sont réalisés surtout interprété et de
l'utilisation du cou qui est faite d'une
donnée biologique statistiques à des
fins juridique de droit des jeunes
concernés et de la même façon vous êtes
vous intéressé à cet autre dossier qui a
surgi depuis peu la constitution d'un
fichier des personnes qu'ils
contesteraient les pv justement puisque
vous venez de nous parler de tv voilà
puis je m'arrêterai là pour laisser mes
collègues de poser leurs questions
s'il vous plaît peut-être oui bien sûr
merci de votre présence je sais que vous
vous devez partir très rapidement donc
je vais essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
des questions
la question des locaux quand j'ai pris
mes fonctions au mois de juin
je trouvais quatre institutions qui
étaient chacune chez elle donc la halde
rue saint georges
le médiateur de la république rue saint
florentin la défense des enfants
boulevard blanqui la commission de vente
au logis de la sécurité la tour maubourg
deux sites
florentin et la halde s'était d'ailleurs
les deux sites principaux
nous ne pouvons pas en partir avant 2014
date de la fin du bail
c'était sous un régime de bail privé
bail de neuf ans pas de possibilité de
le dénoncer
voilà j'ai demandé ma france domaine si
par hasard il pourrait trouver une
institution qui pouvait aller à pour
deux ans évidemment on n'a pas trouvé de
substitut donc on est coincé sur ces
deux sites jusqu'en 2014 a en revanche
les deux autres on pouvait dénoncé le
bail avec six mois de préavis
donc on assure un des deux sites
saint-georges loué quelques surfaces
supplémentaires de façon à vouloir
fermer les deux autres sites
donc à partir du mois de 7 en cours de
déménagement disant dus au printemps
nous serons passés de quatre sites à
deux sites et avec une diminution en
surface de l'ordre de 500 m² est
évidemment un coût qui se fera sentir
simplement l'année prochaine parce que
cette année il ya les frais de
déménagement et la station mais un coût
moindre
en termes d'installation et puis
l'objectif évidemment en 2015
c'est d'aller en un seul et même lieu
les rangs de faire le rapprochement de
plusieurs institutions mais comme tels
sont pas sur le même site c'est pas très
facile donc j'ai hâte évidemment qu'on
puisse aller en un seul et même lieu
il est question d'aller dans la grande
opération ségur qui est conduite par le
secrétaire général du gouvernement
mais il y aura un côté ségur et un côté
place de fontenoy derrière l'école
militaire où seraient logés des
autorités administratives indépendantes
défenseur des droits est une île voilà
c'est une hypothèse sur laquelle on
travaille la communication j'ai pas
voulu lancer des opérations de des
actions de communication prématurée
parce qu'il fallait d'abord que
l'institution se met vraiment en mode de
fonctionnement toute opération de
communication peut se traduire par une
augmentation du nombre des dossiers
je voulais pas risquer la saturation
dans une période qui était délicate
puisqu'il fallait à la fois construire
l'institution nouvelle construire un
nouvel organigramme dans le dialogue
avec les agents et avec les
représentants syndicaux dans un des
excellents climat sur le plan social
d'ailleurs et avec une très forte
adhésion des agents des collaborateurs
au processus de rapprochement
alors évidemment vous pouvez l'imaginer
durant la période d'incertitude avant le
vote de la réforme il y avait au
contraire bord une réaction de plus tôt
d'hostilité alizés du rapprochement
une fois que le cap a été franchi au
contraire on a vu une dynamique très
très très positive avec par exemple je
ne sais chief au moment du vote pour
l'élection des des instances paritaires
à niveau de participation de combien
monsieur me faire le participation aux
élections
70% et pas beaucoup d'observer
d'administration on observe un taux de
participation de 70% au aux élections
luc machard directeur général des
services travaille en ce moment à la
construction du cadre d'emplois en
dialogue avec
les représentants syndicaux et puis
compte tenu des contraintes
le problème principal étant que ces
quatre structures avec des systèmes de
rémunération très différents certains
avaient des primes d'hôtes avait pas de
prime
certains avaient le ticket restaurant
d'autres ne l'avait pas certaines
avaient des systèmes de pointage pour à
la mesure de présence doute ne l'avez
pas vous pouvez pas imaginer plus
grandes disparités
il a fallu voilà aussi bien sur
l'organisation du temps de travail que
sur les questions de rémunérations et de
primes
arrivé dans une enveloppe budgétaire
contrainte à harmoniser alors tout se
fera pas la première année voilà mais
ont fait converger vers le haut est ce
qu'on fera pas garder indéfiniment dans
un même bureau des personnes qui ont une
formation équivalente une ancienneté
identiques qui font le même travail avec
30 % l'écart de rémunération et est dès
lors que et ça c'est tout la synergie
on mélange les gens ils ont pu chacun
chez eux forcément les disparités
apparaissent et il faudra quand il
faudra régler ça
aussi vite que possible luc machard y
travaillent donc j'en viens la
communication j'ai pas voulu d'action
prématurée on vient de faire une
première opération sur la région
parisienne sur les réseaux métro bus une
communication qui est basé non pas sur
des promesses ou des concepts théoriques
mais sur les résultats et sur des cas
concrets et le message c'est pas le
nôtre c'est celui du citoyen qui a fait
appel à l'institution et dont on a pu
résoudre le problème et le dit lui même
voilà donc c'est sur cette communisme
des personnes mais par exemple la
personne les pv et qui dit que j'étais
je croyais devenir fou bon ben voila mon
problème a été résolu pur n'explique
histoire et est maintenant je vais
essayer pour des raisons d'économie de
développer des partenariats avec des
collectivités territoriales beaucoup de
d'élus locaux parmi vous à la sonatel
aussi je vous lance pour avoir en
partenariat avec une commune un
département une région une action de
communication de proximité indiquant
notamment où se trouvent les permanences
des délégués du défenseur des droits
dont quelle mairie annexe dans quelle
maison la justice et du droit
donc quel local associatif à quelle
heure façon à ce que voilà et les gens
sachent comment venir vers nous et je
crois que c'est un partenariat qui est
dans l'intérêt des deux parties à la
fois de la collectivité et de
l'institution du défenseur des droits
la question des tests osseux à l'ess
pourrez pas vous répondre sur le fond
ainsi l'adjoint de défense des enfants
étaient là je vous dirais proment où on
a mené une réflexion je sais que c'est
considéré comme un test peu fiable en
tout cas qu'il ait ressenti une très
grande marge de l'ordre de 3 ans
d'erreurs d'appréciation sur le fait de
savoir s'il s'agit ou pas d'un mineur
j'en ai parlé d'ailleurs récemment dans
votre
département puisque j'ai rencontré le
président du conseil général qui m'a
demandé de venir voir son dispositif
mineurs isolés étrangers et un
dispositif très développés puisque vous
êtes le troisième département de france
après paris et la seine saint denis pour
le nombre de mineurs donc j'ai beaucoup
parlé de ces questions avec lui je peux
pas vous donner une position tranchée
je sais qu'il ya un problème et
notamment d'incertitude autour de ce
test les fichiers des personnes qui
présentent de réclamations sur les pv je
suis pas compétent pour vous dire que si
ça pose un problème du point de vue
juridique
là on est pleinement dans les
compétences de de la cnil se séparent
servent à un sujet dont il est bon je
vais avec alma par an piété sur les
alors on peut produire avec la cnil par
exemple je vous disais un travail en
commun mais en revanche me substituer à
elle pour juger de la pertinence quand
on en a eu des échanges de ce nom en
étant l'assurer que puisqu'en principe
on va vivre ensemble à partir de 2015
mais on n'a pas eu sur ce sujet j'ai
oublié je vous prie de m'excuser de vous
remercier
puisque on bénéficie du concours très
précieux d'un administrateur ici de la
commission monsieur les niches qui est
venu chez nous il reviendra au sénat
j'en suis convaincu mais il est venu
chez nous j'apprécie beaucoup son
efficacité sa compétence et sa
motivation d'autant plus que voilà il
avait suivi le processus de
l'élaboration de l'institution et merci
encore de loi permet de venir chez nous
merci pour vos réponses
alors monsieur g l'armada mme borvo je
suis ok tôt mais ses qualités du bac
monsieur lézard monsieur lecerf voilà et
puis après on
on apprit deuxième phase
messieurs défenseur des droits cela veut
dire au revoir au sénat justement je
commençais à m'inquiéter de ne pas vous
voir parce que je sais à quel point
c'était difficile de remettre en place
l'institution que vous présidez
néanmoins et j'ai quelques
interrogations à à vous soumettre la
première est ce que vous êtes satisfait
du travail que le sénat avait réalisé en
rédigeant la loi organique puisque c'est
notre oeuvre
en réalité et non pas l'oeuvre
gouvernementale à l'époque oui d'abord
mais ensuite la loi organique
et est ce que vous êtes satisfait des
textes qui vous régis ou est-ce que vous
estimez qu'il doivent être corrigés
premiers points 2e fois vous avez donc
en parlais tout à l'heure de la
communication répondants madame caisse
je suis un peu un peu sur la réserve là
parce que je trouve que la lisibilité du
défenseur des droits est pas très très
bien ressenti encore qui a un effort à
faire
on connaissait le défenseur des enfants
connaissaient on connaissait pas le la
déontologie c'était très mal connue on
connaissait la halde
grâce à une publicité extraordinaire
fait sur des radios périphériques mais
on ne connaissait assez bien le
médiateur parce que votre prédécesseur
dans cette fonction savait faire de la
publicité de là il ya un peu à un manque
à mon avis qu'il va falloir combler
parce que le vidame en jeu je comprends
votre crainte de voir le nombre des
requêtes s'élever aussi durablement
mais je crois que même que le défenseur
des droits pourra prendre sa place
pleine et entière dans l'édifice
institutionnel qui est qui est le nôtre
alors ensuite et
j'ai quelques petites interrogations de
détail et je suis pas convaincu que les
réseaux ont fonctionné tout de suite
très bien
un exemple j'ai été amené à écrire au
défenseur des droits par l'intermédiaire
du délégué local et j'ai jamais eu de
réponse
alors ça me ça me gêne j'ai une réponse
sur l'une des demandes que j'ai fait
mais pas sur une autre même si c'est un
acte simple accusé de réception
je pense que c'est utile pour savoir qui
c'est bien parvenu et ça c'est un
premier point le deuxième point j'ai
appris que le médiateur de la république
avait un réseau dents au sein des
établissements de détention et il
semblerait que ce réseau soit interrompu
non bon alors très bien et dernière
petite question
l'acca dan est toujours rattaché nulle
part et d'autre part nous avons monsieur
delarue qu'il terminera ses fonctions
dans un proche avenir
je voudrais savoir si le défenseur des
droits estime qu'il y as peut-être lieu
d'absorber ces institutions le moment
venu ou au contraire qu'elles gardent
leur indépendance aussi concerne la
cadac elles sont rattachées à la cnil
merci monsieur généreux peut-être pour y
répondre et c'est sur l'isolément qui
lui rapportait l'organique bien sûr
qu'il a plusieurs questions et
qu'ensuite je pense que nos collègues
auront une seule question tout à fait
d'accord bien sûr belle écoute et très
heureux de venir devant la commission à
la suite de cette invitation
j'étais déjà venu au sénat depuis mon
entrée en fonction pour une réunion de
travail avec madame claisse et pour une
rencontre également avec avec le
président sur b alors moi je suis
preneur
aussi bien ici au sénat qu'à l'assemblée
nationale le tout rencontre avec les
parlementaires bien sûr commission des
lois en priorité commission des finances
sur la gestion de l'institution
je ne demande que ça la loi organique
je vais pas dire sa part flagornerie
mais je trouve qu'elle est qu'elle est
bonne de toute façon voilà mon rôle
c'est d'appliquer cette loi
j'essaye d'être fidèle aussi bien à la
lettre k l'esprit du texte
un exemple le texte dit trois adjoints
tout en ouvrant la possibilité d'
adjoint supplémentaire
j'ai préféré m'en tenir aux trois
joueurs pour être aussi proche que
possible de l'architecturé qui a été
dessiné par le parlement et j'ai bien le
parlement parce que je sais bien que ce
texte en raison justement des
inquiétudes suscitées par ce
rapprochement a fait l'objet de beaucoup
de navettes de beaucoup de modifications
d'un travail très intense de la part de
beaucoup de parlementaires très impliqué
et je pense que c'est un texte
voilà qui va nous permettre de donner
une pleine efficacité dans l'accès aux
droits des citoyens
grâce à cette institution nouvelle alors
aujourd'hui on travaille plutôt sur la
question des décrets notamment
concernant notre pouvoir de proposition
de réforme
un projet de décret en ce moment entre
matignon et la chancellerie mais
franchement le dispositif législatif
on l'a fait fonctionner sans aucune
difficulté
et si vous me disiez mais ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on pourrait modifier ceci ou
cela je ne pourrais même pas même pas
vous dire oui il ya quand même une
difficulté qui viennent voilà on n'a pas
identifiés je me tourne vers richard
senghor qui le secrétaire-général
d'institutions d'accord
oui dans le domaine nouveau qui est le
vôtre c'est à dire des rapports
exclusivement privée par exemple entre
employeurs et salariés
ça c'est nouveau par rapport aux médias
oui mais pas par rapport à l' bas par
rapport à la balle
oui j écoutais jeu à la réflexion riels
seule chose mais encore une fois y'a pas
l'urgence et on essaye de 10 voir clair
on va peut-être demander au conseil
d'état une interprétation on peut par
exemple dans une affaire de déontologie
de la sécurité
si le le le juge pénal et saisi un juge
d'instruction instruit le dossier
on peut lui demander communication du
dossier
il ne peut pas nous opposer le secret de
l'instruction s'est dit dans texte mais
en même temps on ne dit pas qu'il est
tenu de nous le donner
c'est un profond il peut nous le refuse
et il suffit qu'ils ne motive pas son
refus par le secret de l'instruction
ce qui est quand même voilà c'est la
seule ambiguïté que alex près huit mois
d'expérience on est décelé dans le
dispositif
oui dans les faits ça ne pose pas de
problème parce que voilà les les
échanges sont très fluides avec avec
l'autorité judiciaire monsieur le
sénateur sur la question de la
visibilité enfin ou de la commune de la
visibilité évoqué également pas même que
j'accepte tout à fait le reproche
et ce reproche va m'aider parce que je
suppose que ça figurera au procès verbal
si je suis comment dirais-je sigéric une
certaine tempérance dans ce domaine
pendant quelques mois c'était pour pas
être submergé par une vague de deux
dossiers
aujourd'hui on est tout à fait en mesure
de les traiter la seconde raison c'est
que lisant les débats notamment en
commission au sujet des autorités
administratives précédente
bon j'ai vu que parfois les dépenses de
communication avait été jugée excessive
donc voilà je n'engage ses dépenses de
communication que d'une main tremblante
d'autant plus qu'on est dans une période
qui est pas de facilité sur le plan
budgétaire mais ce que vous me dites ce
que me dit votre collègue d'ille et
vilaine voilà je vais me sentir plus à
l'aise je vais pas lancer des campagnes
avec un coût faramineux mais c'est vrai
que par exemple on pourrait prendre
notamment la presse quotidienne
régionale
on pourrait prendre de temps en temps
une demi-page pour présenter
l'institution bon mais voilà j'essaye de
trouver des espaces de communication
gratuit c'est pour ça que je parlais de
partenariat avec les collectivités
locales
mais je pense aussi qu'il faudra qu'on
prenne un peu de communication payante
parce que parce que sinon on aura du mal
au mois de juillet juste après mon
entrée en fonction j'avais j'avais
demandé une enquête d'opinion à 6g
service d'information du gouvernement
qui fait les aider les enquêtes sur la
notoriété de l'institution
en gros ça donnait 50 % des français
enfin des personnes interrogées
n'avaient pas entendu parler 25% en
avait entendu parler et savais pas ce
que c'était et 25% en avait entendu
parler et estimé savoir ce que c'était
bon voilà ce que je dis c'est que faut
toujours positiver ça donne des marges
de progression
parce qu au même moment dans la même
enquête évidemment le médiateur de la
république ou la lddhi bénéficier de 60
à 70 % de notoriété donc des
institutions qui ont disparu sont plus
connus encore maintenant qu'une
institution qui vient d'apparaître
il faudra un an deux ans pour que
progressivement tout ça s'installe dans
l'esprit du public
mais je tiens compte de ce que vous me
dites moi ça me libère d'une certaine
manière et je vais demander à monsieur
macha d'inscrire quelques crédits
supplémentaires en communication et 6,6
dans le programme responsable du
programme nous demandent pourquoi on
augmente cette ligne d'irak s'est
poursuivie l'avis du parlement
le réseau désolé si vous avez eu des
démarches sans réponse
on va relancer les délégués de votre
département
bon il ya eu quelques mois de flottement
il ya eu quelques mois de flottement bon
j'ai tout de suite en prenant mes
fonctions dit à l'ensemble des délégués
des trois réseaux vous êtes confirmés
continue etc
mais bon il ya eu un peu de flottement
il savait pas si chacun devait continuer
dans son domaine
s'il veut se rapprocher maintenant en
principe ça devrait à nouveau bien
fonctionné c'est quand même un réseau
qui rend énormément de services un peu
de la moitié des dossiers de médiation
sont traités sur le terrain si tout ce
qui était traité par les par les
délégués territoriaux devait remonter à
paris on pourrait pas les traiter à
effectif constant
mais je vais regarder de près ce qui
s'est passé chez vous les prisons on
continue on continue on a 160 délégués
qui vont dans des prisons et tous les
établissements pénitentiaires reçoivent
la visite de délégués du défenseur des
droits
hier c'étaient ceux du médiator à un
public maintenant défenseur des droits
dont certains par exemple qui était
correspondant de la halde le peuvent
venir aussi faire de la médiation en
prison je suis allé dans plusieurs
établissements j'ai mesuré le travail et
son ordinaire qui font parce que il
arrive vraiment à résoudre beaucoup de
problèmes en médiation entre l'accès au
droit
ils sont souvent une sorte de médiateur
entre un détenu et l'administration
pénitentiaire
et puis le problème des relations avec
les administrations extérieur c'est déjà
pas facile pour celui qui est en liberté
de régler ses problèmes de retrait de
cela celui qui est en présence encore
plus difficile et d'ailleurs on voit
bien le pourcentage de saisines venant
de la population pénitentiaire est 50
fois plus élevé que le pourcentage
la population ordinaire donc oui le
dispositif est maintenu on y tient
beaucoup
ça se passe très bien avec
l'administration pénitentiaire et
considère que c'est une aide pour eux et
ça se passe très bien avec avec les
détenus donc maintenant il ya une
couverture générale cas d'un contrôle
général des lieux de privation de
liberté monsieur sénateurs je vous
renvoie la question
la décision appartient au parlement
je sais bien qu'à l'occasion des débats
ces hypothèses ont été évoquées dans
dans votre rapport vous arrivez à me
dessiner un périmètre encore encore plus
large
cada tenir la décision ne nous
appartient pas et formuler une opinion
serait d'une certaine manière prendre
position dans un débat qui à partir
complètement aux parlementaires pour
vous résumer ma pensée mais sans
désigner telle ou telle institution
je pense que si nous réussissons dans
notre mission ça ça va générer une
dynamique de regroupement peut-être pas
forcément d'extension de notre propre
périmètre mais de rapprochement d'autres
institutions donc voilà en matière de
gouvernance en ce que nous faisons est à
tuchan de laboratoire et je crois que si
on réussit pas il peut y avoir d'autres
opérations ce mouvement pas forcément
autour de nouvelles tours d'autres pôles
sur d'autres d'autres sujets pour
réduire le nombre effectivement avoir
trop élevé d'autorités administratives
indépendantes dont tu vois là qu'on
arrive même plus à identifier
merci alors on peut madame borvo
merci oui j'avais aussi une question sur
la visibilité vous avez répondu
enfin vous avez répondu avait dit mais
moi je voulais la pause et un peu
autrement c'est à dire certes vous avez
des pouvoirs que n'avait pas les
autorités auparavant mais c'est vrai que
les autorités s'étaient fait une
notoriété sur leurs spécialités
donc c'est évident que le bon pour le
commun des mains de nos concitoyens le
défense les autorités n'existait sans
doute pas pour l'ensemble nos
concitoyens mais elle existait pour des
populations plus précise et donc vous
avez besoin de faire valoir que
justement vous intéresser ils ont un
spectre plus large et que vous remplacez
les particuliers l'arrêté des autorités
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya besoin d'eux
sinon votre rôle risque de se
restreindre par tout simplement par
méconnaissance du plus grand nombre
voilà alors moi je vais me poser une
question qui n'est pas du tout perf' de
vous savez que j'ai n'ai pas été
favorable à la fusion des autorités mais
bon pas nous parlons présent maintenant
et mais ma question n'est pas du tout
perfide mais néanmoins importante
est-ce que vous n'en avez pas parler
justement de la commission de
déontologie de la sécurité et
est-ce que vous avez été saisie de
dossiers d'un relevé de cette autorité
est précisément parce que c'était la
question est-ce que vous avez exercé
votre pouvoir d'injonction oui bonjour
monsieur le défenseur des droits moi
j'étais très intéressé par ce que vous
avez dit sur la diversité dans
l'entreprise et le travail que vous avez
menées avec la cnil pour pouvoir mesurer
cette diversité parce que c'est vrai
qu'en matière de discriminations en
france on est souvent bloquée par une
vision qu'on n'a pas de la statistique
des populations concernées et je pense
notamment à l'accès au logement
jusqu'au moment département nous allons
à une affaire de discrimination avec un
administrateur qui a tenu des propos un
article 40 de l'association qui ont
saisi la justice
la difficulté principale ça va être de
mesurer la réalité ou non de la
discrimination alors la presse elle a
utilisé en fait la consonance des noms
et lieux des articles dans la presse
avec des journalistes de médiapart pour
ne pas le citer qui ont mesuré en fait
la discrimination en tenant compte de la
consonance des noms donc se sont se sont
livrés à des études statistiques mais on
en voit quand même les limites c'est pas
c'est pas la presse de d'établir
ce type de comptage et donc sur la base
de ce que vous avez comme expérience
pour la mesure de cette diversité dans
l'entreprise
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas trouver des
moyens de généraliser un petit peu cette
expérience est d'avoir un outil qui
permette de mesurer la diversité et la
discrimination
là je prends l'exemple de l'accès au
logement parce que nous y sommes
confrontés
mais je crois qu on est vraiment bloqué
dans cette lutte contre les
discriminations part par là par le peu
de possibilités qu'on a d'avoir un outil
fiable pour mesurer vraiment si la
discrimination pas et puis ensuite vous
avez parlé de la communication donc je
pense en effet qu'il faut développer la
communication de l'institution est en
effet s'appuie aussi sur les sur les
villes moi je suis mes envies de sa
combi d'habitants on est toujours
preneur d'information dans le bulletin
municipal
si l'information est pratique pour nos
concitoyens ont le fait régulièrement
pour informer de changement d'horaire de
bus prend l'air atpdh horaires
d'ouverture des bureaux de poste la
fondation venant du commissariat on
pourrait tout à fait le faire également
si l'information se pratique avec les
coordonnées des personnes à contacter
une explication simple pour que nos
concitoyens puissent facilement
comprendre dans quel cadre
ils peuvent saisir le défenseur des
droits et en s'adressant à kehl à quelle
personne simplement je crois que ça
permettrait de bien bien diffuser aussi
l information merci je remercie musique
a qu'un pas que j'avais cette idée en
tête c'est que vous pourriez quand même
une adresse toute collecte et
territoriales régions départements ou
grandes villes ont tous des butins tous
et je ne pense pas qu'ils refuseraient
d'avoir un article un interview du
médiateur peut-être que vous pourriez
faire un peu pour tout le monde j'en
sais rien et puis localement
mais tout à fait et en fait c'était une
proposition faite à life est bon et
appelé les associations d'élus merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
défenseur des droits personnellement
j'ai été favorable au principe de la
fusion plusieurs autorités mais pas du
pas de l'absorption du cnds pour des
raisons que j'avais exposé et
rebondissant sur la question de la
présidente borvo je souhaitais savoir
quel était votre vision de l'évolution
du travail de du défenseur des droits
par rapport à ces questions de
déontologie et de sécurité parce que ça
me paraît au niveau des principes
extrêmement important donc je souhaitais
savoir quel était votre vision
personnelle et puis deuxièmement
deuxième génération sur le périmètre
j'ai pu constater encore récemment
encore la semaine dernière que il ya un
problème de périmètre avec les
conciliateurs de justice qui dans un
souci positif avec beaucoup de bonne
volonté
finalement assez souvent empiète sur ce
qu'est le travail du défenseur des
droits sur le terrain et je souhaitais
savoir si vous aviez envisagé une
concertation avec le ministère de la
justice là dessus merci alors monsieur
monsieur dessert qui se bat même ce sont
des droits je souhaiterais revenir sur
une question qui a déjà été posée par
patrice gélard mais en l'élargissant un
peu qui concerne effectivement le monde
carcéral
vous nous avez dit qu' il n'y avait pas
de changement au niveau des délégués des
anciens délégués du médiateur dans les
établissements pénitentiaires
bon moi si j'ai pas constaté de
changement au niveau des délégués dans
les préfectures
moi qui visitent souvent les
établissements pénitentiaires j'ai été
confronté récemment effectivement à soit
la disparition
le délégué ne vient plus soit à une
certaine forme de caractère orphelin il
se demandait un peu effectivement de qui
dépendent et il est peut-être utile de
l'est n'ont pas de les reprendre en main
mais de rassurer un peu ces différentes
personnes vous nous disiez d'autre part
que les choses se passaient bien avec
l'admission pénitentiaire alors je ne
sais pas si ça me rassure aussi ça
m'inquiète si vous voulez je constate
que pour le travail du contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté ça se passe pas très bien et
qu'il ya une résistance de
l'administration pénitentiaire ne
serait-ce qu'à sa saisine par les
personnes détenues mais c'est vrai que
les compétences sont différentes et les
interventions de de vos représentants
sont plutôt des interventions qui font
baisser la pression
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi donc on peut
comprendre que la pénitentiaire est
peut-être une appréhension différente
ce qui m'intéressait aussi et moi
c'était une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'étais favorable au regroupement des
institutions y compris la cnds c'est que
je constatais que le travail de la cnds
était assez remarquable mais que
l'efficacité de son travail il était
beaucoup moins et qu'il arrivait
notamment que dans des hypothèses où il
y avait des problèmes de déontologie
avec les personnels de surveillance des
mutations pénitentiaire on met bien en
évidence ces problèmes mais qu'il n'y a
guère de sanction puisque moi je
retrouvais en visitant un établissement
les mêmes personnes qui auraient dû être
sanctionnés alors est-ce que sur ce
point
déjà mais c'est peut-être un peu trop
rapide vous vous êtes forger une opinion
sur le travail du défenseur des droits
en matière de contrôle de la déontologie
des personnels de surveillance notamment
de la pénitentiaire est est-ce qu
éventuellement là aussi vous pourriez
utiliser votre pouvoir d'injonction
merci monsieur bah merci monsieur le
président je voudrais revenir sur un
point qui a déjà été abordé celui de
l'information il me semble que beaucoup
des problèmes qui sont examinées par
votre institution doivent pouvoir se
régler localement j'apprécie que votre
réseau soit constituée et renforcé j'ai
l'impression toutefois que l'étendue de
vos pouvoirs n'est pas bien connue des
administrations de l'état localement et
donc je voulais vous faire la suggestion
mais peut-être l'avez-vous déjà mise en
oeuvre de densifier les rencontres avec
les préfets et éventuellement de pouvoir
vous adresser collectivement à eux car
c'est eux qui détiennent l'autorité
nécessaire pour régler les problèmes
localement et ce serait dommage de ne
pas profiter de leurs investissements
dans ce domaine va répondre à cela
d'abord parce que et après on reprend
non alors il gérait chabada mouche
oui merci monsieur le président c'est et
merci monsieur le président de me passer
la parole en fait je voulais simplement
abondé dans le sens de mes collègues et
tout particulièrement la dernière
intervention sur le défenseur des droits
concernant l'information
non seulement j'ai le sentiment que
l'administration de l'état dans les
départements n'est pas suffisamment
informée effectivement de 2,2 du
périmètre de vos interventions
mais les associations porteuses intérêt
non plus j'ai comme tous les collègues
ici eu à être à connaître de difficulté
par le biais d'associations porteuse
intérêts qui nous demandent d'intervenir
précisément pour faire reconnaître des
droits de l'un de l'autre de leurs
ressortissants et souvent je me suis
posé la question comment ces
associations qui pourtant ont pignon sur
rue
kiki comtois ont notamment pour vocation
de défendre les intérêts de leurs
ressortissants leurs adhérents dans des
domaines d'activités qui sont les leurs
non pas connaissance de vos activités
est ce qu'il y a là des relations avec
des associations
je sais bien que c'est une des bulls des
associations de femmes en local mais il
a quelques unes qui sont fédérés au
niveau national est ce que des contacts
sont d'ores et déjà pris entre entre
vous même le cas échéant vous déléguez
sur le terrain et ses associations enfin
comment améliorer la situation
je ne dépose pas à chaque fois que je
suis un tueur mutuellement interpellé
j'essaye d'apporter ma contribution mais
encore une fois je suis persuadé que je
le ferais de toute façon largement moins
bien que ce que vous pourriez mettre en
oeuvre même bouche ou bien pris on
simplement relayé une demande d'un
certain nombre d'associations notamment
celles qui me concernant la prise en
compte de l'orientation sexuelle qui
aimerait vraiment que en région dans les
préfectures et les sous-préfectures vous
fassiez la masse et la bonne parole
puisque la tendance depuis deux trois
ans et d'éviter les associations je
dirais qu'ils sont trop
interventionniste notamment domaine de
revendications concernant les droits
donc je vous relève notamment le message
de l'association casa ranger qui
aimerait vraiment bien que toutes les
associations soient prises en compte
dans leur diversité qui compte sur vos
nouvelles missions pour que les choses
avancent on merci
monsieur vous dise ancien des repentis
vous vous aurez appris alors je vais
essayer de répondre à l'ensemble des
questions
madame à bordeaux sur la communication
je partage entièrement votre approche
l'une des difficultés de l'exercice
c'est au delà du nom magnifique de
défenseur des droits de bien expliquer
quelles sont les missions faute de quoi
d'ailleurs on pourrait être submergés de
demandes qui n'enlève pas forcément de
nous donc la communication enfin celle
qu'on a commencé sur métro bus et qu'on
voudrait développer maintenant plus
largement elle porte sur des cas
concrets par exemple l'histoire de deux
petites filles qui se trouvait bloqué
dans un pays africain
leur mère avait perdu les papiers et les
passeports et elles ne pourraient pas
rentrer à la rentrée scolaire du mois de
septembre
la situation était très compliquée sur
le plan juridique parce que la mer était
né au congo l'époque où il était belge
dont l état civil va être belle fable
vous pouvez imaginer
on est intervenu pour démêler cette
affaire
à la satisfaction d'une association très
active comme réseau éducation sans
frontières que vous connaissez sans
doute et qui nous a publiquement adressé
un message en nous remerciant d'avoir
permis donc voilà on raconte cette
histoire en quelques mots on raconte
celui dans
allez 45 pv bon ont été annulés on
raconte le problème d'une femme qui
pouvaient pas accéder à ses droits à la
retraite
on est intervenu on a pu l'arrêter bien
et doit donc plutôt par des définitions
juridiques un peu abstraite et général
on illustre par des cas concrets nos
domaines d'intervention
et puis comme les jambons sont toujours
sceptiques vis à vis des promesses qu'on
illustre avec des résultats sur la
question de la déontologie de la
sécurité
question qui m'a été également posée par
plusieurs de vos collègues
c'est le domaine où le nombre de
dossiers que nous recevant a le plus
augmenté
pourquoi auparavant seuls les députés
les sénateurs pouvaient saisir la cnf
aujourd'hui évidemment je reçois parfois
un des dossiers transmis par des
parlementaires mais tout citoyen peut
saisir le défenseur des droits au titre
de sa mission de veille sur la
déontologie de la sécurité
résultat nous avions une quinzaine de
dossiers par mois nous sommes passés à
50 dossiers par mois
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il ya trois
fois plus de dérapages et de manquement
à la déontologie ça veut dire que
l'accès au droit est plus large plus
facile on peut être saisie d'ailleurs
non seulement parce qu'ils sont victimes
mais pas les témoins également donc une
cinquantaine de dossiers par mois des
quatre missions c'est celle dont le
volume d'activité a augmenté le plus
fortement
alors on a pris pour playa de type de
dossier il ya des dossiers
qui relève pas de décisions lourdes
beaucoup de dossiers sur lesquels on
demande au ministère de l'intérieur
d'engager des poursuites disciplinaires
contre les fonctionnaires de police
depuis mon entrée en fonction
ça a dû arriver pour une dizaine de cas
alors évident comme ce sont des
décisions lourdes de conséquences
à l'occasion de faits qui eux mêmes ont
été lourds de conséquences parce que
voilà il ya des blessés graves parfois
ya des décès ça fait l'objet d'une
instruction longue contradictoires dans
laquelle on s'efforce à l'impartialité
et ensuite une décision du collège et
toutes les décisions du collège
demandant des poursuites disciplinaires
ont été prises à l'unanimité
voilà un mot sur la personne à qui j'ai
confié le soin naître mon adjointe sur
la déontologie de la sécurité
c'était vraiment le profil je crois
qu'il convenait pour cette mission parce
que c'est une femme qui a été avocate
pendant 15 ans ensuite elle est devenu
magistrat du parquet ensuite dans le
cadre de sa mobilité
elle a travaillé pendant deux ans à la
direction générale de la gendarmerie
puis pendant deux ans à la préfecture de
police
puis pendant deux ans à l'administration
pénitentiaire et elle est revenue au
parquet donc finalement elle connaît
toutes les facettes des sujets dont dont
nous traitons alors sur la question
est-ce que vous user des pouvoirs
nouveaux qui vous sont donnés par la loi
oui jusqu'à présent la cnds
voilà recommander des poursuites
disciplinaires mais dans neuf cas sur
dix les recommandations n'étaient pas
suivies d'effet
les recommandations générales concernant
la formation permanente et cetera
pouvait l'être sur les mesures
individuelles non nous avons maintenant
la capacité donc d'injonction et si
notre demande n'est pas suivi d'effet
nous avons ça c'est le dernier niveau
auquel nous pouvons intervenir la
capacité et je serai proment a mené
recouvrir bientôt faute de réponse
satisfaisante de publier un rapport
spécial au journal officiel
par ailleurs nous avons un guerrier ça
la cnds ne l'avait pas nous avons
également la capacité
si une personne qui a été victime de
manquement un déontologie de la sécurité
qui a subi des dommages corporels
saisi par exemple une juridiction
administrative pour demander des
dommages à l'état on a la capacité de
déposer des observations auprès de la
juridiction
et par ailleurs j'observe que dans
beaucoup d'affaires pénales parce que
bien souvent il ya une procédure au
pénal
quant à lui à mort les les réquisitions
du parquet et le jugement bien souvent
reprenne les termes qui était bière ce2
de la cnds aujourd'hui du défenseur des
droits
donc davantage de demande davantage de
moyens d'action une petite difficulté
c'est qu'il faut qu'on gère cette
augmentation de la demande
j'ai passé une convention avec l'école
nationale de la magistrature de bordeaux
et on accueille on vient de recevoir la
semaine dernière des stagiaires qui sont
à l'école nationale de la magistrature
mais qui ont été recrutés sur titres et
qui auparavant était avocat alors les
élèves de le nm doivent obligatoirement
passer six mois chez un avocat dans le
cadre de leur formation
mais avant ce qui était avocat
auparavant sa présente aucun intérêt et
docks le directeur de l'école nous nous
envoie des stagiaires qui permet de
renforcer notre pôle déontologie de la
sécurité
monsieur kalt un mac sur la question des
discriminations
alors je vous signale on peut la trouver
sur notre site à que nous avons en
poursuivant ce que faisait la halde nous
avons une enquête cette année avec
l'organisation internationale du travail
sur la question des discriminations dans
le monde du travail avec deux
échantillons et aux emplois publics
emploi privé et avec certes un focus
particulier en particulier pas un
bouche-trou sur la question lgbt et les
discriminations liées à l'orientation
sexuelle
donc à ce travail d'observation qui est
intéressant rapproché des enquêtes
précédentes puisque la halde avait fait
pendant quatre années
c'était donc la cinquième la cinquième
édition ce que vous avez évoqué sur le
l'analyse patronymique des effectifs
d'une entreprise
en fait c'est une procédure à laquelle
la halde a eu recours dans une affaire
qui vient de connaître récemment sa
conclusion définitive avec une
condamnation de l'entreprise d'ailleurs
est une entreprise moi que je connais
bien puisqu'il s'agit d'airbus qui a été
condamné pour discrimination pour
raisons d'origine à la suite d'une
plainte déposée par
à un ouvrier qui avait été pendant
plusieurs mois sur un poste puis les
verts un recrutement sur ce même poste
il n'a pas été recruté c'est une
personne une qualification beaucoup plus
élevé qui a été recruté donc il avait
saisi la justice
il avait saisi la halle airbus a été
condamné en appel et en cassation
et alors la décision de la cour de
cassation a d'autant plus importante que
la halde à l'époque avait utilisé une
méthode qu'on pouvait qualifier de
lazard 2 sur le plan juridique et fait
une analyse patronymique des effectifs
qui faisaient apparaître que il y avait
quasiment pas de personnes dont les noms
étaient à consonance du maghreb alors il
ya beaucoup de diversité dans
l'entreprise airbus a connu il ya
beaucoup d'anglais d'espagnol d'italien
beaucoup d'européens met beaucoup de
coeur et la cour de cassation a validé
le jugement
enfin l'arrêt de la cour d'appel c'est à
dire invalidé 7,7 cette méthode
bon cela dit là on va avoir maintenant
selon ge parlais tout à l'heure
cet outil élaboré avec la cnil donc là
on sera sur un terrain juridique
absolument incontestable pour pouvoir
mesurer la diversité dans l'entreprise
ce sera un outil pour les responsables
qui qui veulent avoir une politique de
recrutement plus plus inclusif sur le
logement fha ya beaucoup d'actions de
promotion des droits qui avait été fait
par la halde il ya toujours des combats
à livrer je vous raconte cette histoire
par exemple est toute récente
on avait été saisi par trois personnes
handicapées de différentes régions de
france d'ailleurs
pour la même raison elle voulait louer
un appartement ou un studio elle s'était
adressée au réseau foncia qui est le
premier réseau en europe et la location
leur avait été refusée au motif que dans
leur dossier de ressources figuré
l'allocation adulte handicapé on avait
interrogé l'entreprise mais qu'est ce
que c'est réponse de l'entreprise mais
oui bien sûr
puisque l'allocation adulte handicapé
n'est pas saisissable est une ressource
non saisissable donc on estime que le
locataire n'offrent pas les garanties
suffisantes
vous imaginez si tous les opérateurs du
marché immobilier locatif adopte la même
règle et si le plus gros le fait
pourquoi les autres ne serait-il pas
mais c'est à dire qu'une personne
handicapée peut plus accéder aux
logements locatifs et puis si on prend
les ressources non saisissable les
pensions alimentaires sont pas
saisissable donc à soi femmes qui
disposent une pension alimentaire peut
plus louer non plus donc on a adopté une
recommandation demandant à foncia de
donner des instructions à tout son
réseau pour mettre fin à ce dispositif
discriminatoire ce que foncia a fait
immédiatement si on était allé en
justice un gameplay deux ans là on a pu
régler le problème rapidement la
question monsieur ménard du conciliateur
qui est c'est vous qui avez
effectivement le conciliateur est fait
de la médiation entre personnes privées
si on veut si on veut comparer à nous on
est dans la médiation avec des
administrations et services publics
ce qui veut dire par exemple ça veut pas
dire que ça se chevauchent pas dans la
réalité mais par exemple si une personne
vient nous voir nous disant vous êtes de
délégués du défenseur des droits
j'ai un droit au repos comme tout le
monde et le chien de mon voisin à bois
toute la nuit si les avoirs le délégué
du défenseur de voir on ne peut rien
faire pour lui sauf lui conseiller
d'aller voir le conciliateur de justice
voilà c'est mais bon les cetc pas
toujours clair dans l'esprit des gens
les délégués en prison donc il
alors bon il arrive qu avant mais il
peut y avoir un vide pendant une petite
période parce que le pan de nos délégués
se sont comme je voulais tout à l'heure
de nouveaux retraités de jeunes
retraités
mais au bout de cinq ans il en sait tant
voilà il commence à 64,65 arriver à 70
ans ils ont moins envie de continuer il
y en a qui vont beaucoup plus loin
d'ailleurs mais il arrive que certains
s'arrêtent et il faut parfois un mois
deux mois trois mois pour trouver la
bonne personne pour prendre le relais
d'envoi d'une façon générale ou en
prison
alors il faut pas du tout le même
travail que le contrôleur général contre
leurs effets du contrôle
ils forment la médiation voilà par
exemple autres jours à la prison de
poissy
je trouvais un délégué un jeune retraité
qui venait du privé d'ailleurs émises et
a parfois des détenus qui sont des gens
qui viennent pas nous parler de leur
propre cas personnel mais qui parle
d'une d'un problème général par exemple
à la prison de poissy et des cellules où
la température était à peine supportable
est extrêmement chaud et d'autres musées
très froid ces pannes de chauffage
central de vieux bâtiments
voilà et a détenu est allé voir le
délégué
lui a parlé de ça est bon il s'était
déjà plaint les détenus mais là c'est le
délégué qui est allé voir le directeur
de la prison il se met autour d'une
table ils ont fait faire un devis et il
y avait cinquante mille euros
d'investissement à faire pour moderniser
le système de chauffage central
voila voila c'est vrai le type
d'affaires dans lequel ils peuvent
intervenir très très utilement mais
évidemment ils sont dans une autre
posture que les le contrôleur général et
nous mêmes d'ailleurs on peut se trouver
dans une autre posture et est ce que
j'ai dit c'est que nos délégués qui vont
en prison ne doivent pas s'occuper des
questions d anthologie des services de
sécurité parce qu'ils peuvent pas être
un jour en position de médiateur entre
un détenu à l'administration
pénitentiaire et le lendemain revenir en
disant je veux auditionné tel gardien
qui sait peut-être mal conduit vis-à-vis
de telle détenus et donc pour les
questions de déontologie de la sécurité
en milieu pénitentiaire on utilise
d'autres personnes que nono délégué
monsieur bah oui ce travail j'ai
commencé à le faire j'avais demandé au
ministre de l'intérieur d'être conviés à
une conférence des préfets lacombe y en
a tous les mois et demi environ
nous sommes allés quand monde et sont au
mois de décembre donc l ensemble des
préfets je leur ai expliqué en 10
minutes mais bon voilà après il faut que
ça descende faut que ça s'imprime bien
dans l'esprit de tout le monde
voilà ce que je retire de cette
rencontre et vous j'en étais conscient
mais je vois que c'est une nécessité et
vous mais encouragé c'est d'intensifier
l'effort de communication aussi bien en
direction du public en direction d
administration puis monsieur richard
faisait parler des associations alors
bon avec les associations je le fais
beaucoup je passe à peu près la moitié
de mon temps à recevoir les grandes
associations
l'uniopss amnistie international atd
quart monde de la cimade l'apa rouge
bond en valais l'association les luttes
contre les discriminations licra membres
la liste est intervient après aussi il
faut que ça voilà il faut que ça diffuse
faut que ça descende dans les dents les
unions départementales la girolle
rentrer dans une phase de rencontres
avec les grandes centrales syndicales
j'ai rencontré le mois dernier tout des
syndicats de police bon j'y passe à peu
près la moitié de mon temps mais c'est
vrai qu'après ça passe pas forcément
bien en région
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
je me déplace régulièrement au moins un
jour par semaine je vais dans une région
dans une autre j'étais en pays de loire
mois de vendredi dernier pour signer une
convention coeur le président du conseil
régional en région ça me permet de
réunir nos délégués qui sont une
quinzaine environ par parent gens de
parler un petit peu à la presse
régionale de voir les les élus locaux
les collectivités locales qui le
souhaitent
voilà éventuellement de rencontrer le
procureur de la république voilà deux de
se faire de se faire connaître
bon je n'aurais pas non plus mais le
faire de manière trop tapageuse au début
parce que voilà on se fait reprocher
aussi mais je crois que voilà maintenant
qu'on est bien organisé le moment est
venu se faire mieux connaître
merci à vous madame pour le g8 est bon
je vous ai répondu
incidemment à propos du barreau ma des
discriminations emploi ont fait un gros
travail en direction de ce réseau
d'ailleurs on a un comité que j'ai
réunis cette semaine soit pas le comité
d'entente qui avait été créé à l'époque
de la halde ou deux fois par an on a une
réunion avec les principales
associations
on se donne deux ou trois objectifs
on avait créé un groupe de travail en
sueur lgbt et emploi là on vient de
décider la semaine dernière de monter un
groupe de travail sur les questions très
complexes transgenres donc j'ai été
amené je le rappelais tout à l'heure à
voile a préconisé que l'on mette fin à
la discrimination des homosexuels hommes
sur le don du sang
j'avais également appuyer une demande un
projet de réforme enfin banque est
évidemment des incidences financières
considérables qui est la pension de
reversions pour les personnes pacsées
on travaille beaucoup avec le ministère
de la fonction publique pour que dans
l'administration il ya une pratique
unique concernant les jours de congés à
l'occasion d'un pacs il ya des
administrations qui donne deux jours de
congés à l'occasion du tax comme à
l'occasion du mariage
d'autres ne le font pas donc on essaye
d'avoir un régime unique voilà il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce
domaine et on y travaille en relation
étroite avec les associations concernées
merci en attendant que vous ayez
peut-être d'autres questions il faudrait
imposer une au moins est ce que vous
avez eu le temps d'avoir déjà des
relations avec vos collègues étrangers
au moins ont repris oui et puis après si
vous avez encore ne partez pas tout
parce que monsieur cost arrive
oui j'ai eu
des relations avec mes homologues dans
différents cadres bon il ya des cadres
je dirais institutionnels qui sont ce
soit de l'union européenne soit du
conseil de l'europe alors dans dans les
autres pays européens union ou
conseillent les organisations sont très
variables
il ya parfois comme en france maintenant
comme en espagne où il ya défenseur du
peuple
en france un défenseur du droit avec des
compétences larges il ya d'autres pays
où on est au contraire sur du sectoriel
mais qui n'est pas toujours le même
parfois il ya une institution spécifique
pour l'égalité homme femme qui est
distinct de l'institution de lutte
contre les discriminations bref dans
chaque pays il ya une architecture
simplement on rencontre c'est tous ces
acteurs dans différents réseaux alors en
dehors de ces deux réseaux l'union
européenne et conseil de l'europe il y a
il y a le réseau francophone avec une
quarantaine dont bout de semaine et de
médiateur là je pense qu'on a un rôle
important à jouer puisque on voit dans
beaucoup de pays d'afrique francophone
la mise en place d'institutions d'accès
au droit de médiation évidemment ce sont
des institutions récente il faut qu'elle
arrive à gagner leur indépendance
vis-à-vis du pouvoir et le fait
d'appartenir à un réseau et de pouvoir
s'adosser en quelque sorte au défenseur
des droits en france où à mon homologue
luxembourgeois ou belge voilà ça ça
donne de la force à c'est assez nouveau
médiateur ombudsman qui sont parfois
dans la situation très très difficile
mais il ya pas longtemps d'ailleurs au
togo mon homologue
et elle a dû quitter le pays
précipitamment parce que il avait à la
demande d'une juridiction établi un
rapport sur des faits de torture dont
avait été victime d
prisonniers qui ont été condamnés dans
lequel s'étaient livrés un complot
contre la sécurité de l'état
mais il avait été torturé et pendant le
procès ils ont fait état de ces tortures
la juridiction a confié au défenseur des
droits de l'homme le soin d'enquêter sur
ces tortures il s'est avéré qu'elle
avait bien eu lieu et le président du
tour lui a imposé à un autre rapport que
celui qu'il avait fait lui-même
concluante qui avait pas eu d'abus et
donc pour publier ce rapport a été
obligé de quitter le togo avec ce
rapport sous le bras il a rendu publique
une fois arrivé à paris c'est maintenant
un peu plus rentrer chez lui à face et
on lui dit qu'il peut rentrer mais il
est pas sûr de pouvoir
bon voilà donc à ce réseau francophone
qui est important il ya un autre réseau
alors qui est tout à fait en sommeil
mais qui aura son utilité
c'est le réseau des embouts de semaine
et médiateur de la méditerranée bon
alors il ya mort la personne en syrie en
egypte
ils n'ont pas à renouveler les instances
qui date de l'époque moubarak et donc
sont considérées comme illégitimes
d'algérie je crois qu'il y en a pas il
ya quelqu'un au maroc
voilà je crois que quand les situations
se seront décantées
autour de la méditerranée ce sera un
réseau dans lequel on pourra jouer un
rôle utile
merci une toute petite question avant de
donner la parole monsieur hérisson est
ce que le nouveau défenseur des droits
de l'homme du conseil de l'europe fait
nouveau connaissait non je n'ai pas vu
encore j'ai eu des échanges épistolaires
je dois le rencontrer bientôt je suis
allé à strasbourg mais il n'était pas là
ce jour là pour rencontrer sur bradl a
le nouveau le nouveau président de la
cod h et je verrai prochainement le
nouveau commissaire à qui succède à
monsieur merci monsieur buisson oui
merci
ce président
ce défenseur des droits nous avons eu
l'occasion il ya quelques temps de nous
rencontrer sur la problématique et sur
la présence des gens du voyage en france
je préside actuellement la commission
nationale consultative des gens du
voyage qui n'est pas j'allais dire tout
à fait adaptée à ceux qui nous tous non
pas me le mieux adapté aux
problématiques des gens du voyage qui
pour l'essentiel au bout de quelques
années je peux le dire se résume à des
problèmes de médiation plus que des
problèmes de deux de réflexion je suis
actuellement en train de rédiger comme
parlementaire une proposition de loi je
suis pas le seul d'ailleurs d'évolution
et d'adaptation de la loi besson de 2000
et d'un certain nombre de dispositions
qui émane du rapport pour lequel j'avais
été nommé par le premier ministre qui
s'appelle vers un un statut proche du
droit commun le proche m'a d'ailleurs
été reproché par certaines associations
mais il n'empêche que leurs spécificités
ne serait ce que par leur itinéraire
mode de vie itinérante votre problème
actuellement je suis questionné dans le
cadre d'un rapport la cour des comptes
en disant comment faut-il faire évoluer
cette commission donc mon intervention a
aussi pour but de dire qu' il me semble
que le défenseur des droits
ou tout du moins la commission pourrait
évoluer en direction d'une intégration
et d'une prise en considération par vous
sur le travail essentiel qui consiste en
permanente a essayé en permanence pardon
à essayer de trouver les médiations
nécessaires à leur intégration sur le
territoire compte tenu de leur mode de
vie et dans permanence d'être en quelque
sorte un peu de larbitre entre les
collectivités locales qui de par la loi
ont la responsabilité des aires
d'accueil
et puis une autre problématique qui est
mis cultuelle me culturel qui consiste
au moins pour toute une période de
l'année à des déplacements en nombre sur
le territoire qui sont un véritable
cauchemar pour certains traumatismes
pour d'autres et il me semble que
vous pourriez j'ai à dire mettre en
perspective le rôle que peut jouer le
défenseur des droits dans cette
problématique d'autant que plus
particulièrement france que dans les
autres pays de l'union européenne
l'amalgamé est plus fort chez nous avec
les populations roms qui viennent et qui
utilise le mode de vie des gens du
voyage français pour l'essentiel cet
amalgame où on rejette tout en bloc
alors que si on veut bien prendre en
considération d'un côté à problèmes
d'immigration de l'autre côté un
problème de mode de vie itinérante sur
nos territoires
ce sont véritablement deux
problématiques différentes qui touche à
l'insertion sociale à la scolarisation à
la recherche d'emploi à la formation
professionnelle etc etc
donc mon appel c'est plus je n'attends
pas de réponse là q mais l'appel c'est
de dire il faudrait vraiment qu'ils
aient quelque part quelqu'un ou une
personne spécialisée chez vous dans
votre organisation pour prendre en
compte cette problématique des gens du
voyage en france
c'est la théorie sur moi je sais et tout
le monde sait dans votre institution le
travail remarquable que vous faites à la
tête de la commission
mais qui voit là pour faire simple merci
de m'aider en tout cas et on a été amené
d'ailleurs à travailler réfléchir
ensemble sur des propositions de
réformes que
que le défenseur des droits a présenté
sur des choses très très simple
d'ailleurs mais qui effectivement sont
sans discriminatoire par exemple un
citoyen français gens du voyage ne peut
s'inscrire sur une liste électorale que
s'il réside dans une même commune depuis
trois ans alors que le droit commun qui
s'applique à chacun ses six mois scam
assez paradoxal de demander à des gens
qui sont des citoyens français de plein
droit qui sont gens du voyage de dire
avec comme vous êtes gens du voyage donc
vous serez obligés de rester trois ans
dans la même commune au lieu de six mois
singulier donc on a demandé un
alignement sur le régime général
récemment également et c'était des élus
locaux qui me l'avait signalé
on a attiré l'attention du ministre de
l'intérieur et des maires sur des
panneaux d'interdiction de stationnement
qui sont libellés d'une façon clairement
discriminatoire
stationnement interdit aux gens du
voyage on peut utiliser d'autres termes
on peut dire aux résidences mobiles gens
du voyage et donc voilà le petit garçon
qui va à l'école chaque matin et qui
passe devant le panneau interdit aux
gens du voyage après lui expliquer que
il faut pas discriminer c'est pas avant
donc il ya une circulaire vallée vous
dis du ministère n'a t-elle voilà attira
l'attention des communes rendement garde
d'utiliser une autre une autre
signalétique et enfin une autre
un autre libéré nous avons également
demandé l'extension de la trêve
hivernale des personnes qui se trouvent
sur un terrain qu'on ne leur coupe pas
l'électricité et l'eau de même que les
personnes qui sont dans ce logement
sédentaires pendant la période de
l'hiver ensuite ce sénateur quand vous
dites faut mettre en position de
médiation entre les gens du voyage et
les collectivités locales pour que et
une politique d'accueil plus plus plus
ouverte général avec les aires de
stationnement pour les grands passages
si je pouvais y arriver
je lui mettrais ma main j'ai pas j'ai
pas la légitimité pour cela parce qu'il
s'agit pas d' de régler nos pommes d'une
personne avec une administration
c'est un peu le point de politique
générale vous savez bien vous savez
mieux que moi parce que vous avez
travaillé de près sur ces questions là
moi je le savais comme maire il ya des
lois qui prévoit que les communes au
delà d'un certain seuil d'habitants
doivent avoir une aire de stationnement
on s'était bien que l'immense majorité
des communes remplit pas cette
obligation les moyens de rétorsion pour
utiliser le préfère général sont pas
utilisés voilà on connais cette
situation depuis 15 ans je ne crois pas
malheureusement être en mesure je peux
peut-être contribué à lui mais je me
bats tout seul
arrivé à adresser cette cette situation
qui effectivement est loin d'être
satisfaisante mais je dirais le rapport
de la cour des comptes là où donc
la commission fait le travail du
défenseur des droits le défenseur et
droit celui de la commission c'est ça
c'est pas écrit aussi clairement c'est
le défenseur mais ça veut dire aussi que
il met en quelque sorte mais avec la
nuance qui convient au proche- et
d'utiliser la présidence pour faire mon
travail de sénateur et inversement
alors que je suis convaincu que le
d'abord nous sommes dans une situation
où il n'y a absolument plus de budget et
que j'assume avec mes collaborateurs
mais collaboratrice parlementaire la
totalité du fonctionnement de la
commission
bon donc là dessus - j'ai pas de souci
est la cour des comptes sur des
problèmes budgétaires n'ayant pas de
budget je suis pas ennuyé avec ça donc
ça va ça va ça va déjà bien par contre
c'est devenu une tribune hélas en
fonction des sensibilités des uns et des
autres un peu trop politique qui fait
que les représentants des ministères du
coup ne disent plus rien du tout elles
créent un certain nombre de difficultés
de fonctionnement de la commission
merci monsieur hérisson dont je crois
qu'on va en rester là il nous reste à
votre nom à tous à remercier le
défenseur des droits pour si votre sa
grande disponibilité pour la précision
de ses réponses car je crois que vous
avez eu droit à des réponses assez
précise et est développé également
j'allais dire pour la transparence dont
il avait fait preuve
l'avis des parlementaires c'est normal
mais ça l'est pas toujours
voilà donc je remercie également
voilà c'est la fin de cette audition de
la commission des lois prochain rendez
vous avec les travaux parlementaires
c'est cet après midi à partir de 17h
vous pourrez suivre en direct l'audition
du juge trévidic par la commission
d'application des lois très belle la
journée à tous
ans